dramatische rettung in pieskow county
florida nördlich von tampa eine
geisterfahrerin ist in der falschen
richtung unterwegs als mit einem ihr
entgegenkommenden auto kollidiert durch
die wucht des aufpralls wurde ihr wagen
in die leitplanke geschleudert und fing
feuer die frau ist in dem wrack
eingeklemmt können sich nicht allein
befreien noch vor der feuerwehr
erreichen erste polizisten die
unfallstelle ohne zu zögern schnappen
sie sich ihre feuerlöscher und versuchen
die flammen einzudämmen
doch es funktioniert nicht immer wieder
bricht das feuer aus und erschwert die
rettungsmaßnahmen die beamten versuchen
die frau über den rücksitz aus dem
brennenden auto zu bekommen doch die
30-jährige ist hinter dem lenkrad
eingeklemmt
bange sekunden vergehen im hintergrund
hört man schon die sirenen der nahenden
feuerwehr doch die polizisten geben
nicht auf schließlich können sie die
überreste der fahrertür soweit auf
biegen dass sie die frau aus dem wrack
ziehen können wie sich später
herausstellt dass die 30 jährige
angetrunken unterwegs gewesen
[Musik]